si vous voulez avec les bonnes années
nous voulons mais c'est moi avec ça on
savait bien que je vous ai je n'ai
jamais répondu à ça mais vous continuez
à m'envoyer des bonnes années
tout le mois de janvier et février etc
s'il vous plaît en plus les mousselines
on a même conviction arrêter avec ça
c'est des ministres et une la plupart
commencent à des frères ont fait pas ça
parce que les compagnies l'ont fêté le
nouvel an abou bakr aussi des coloniaux
mois commentaires mathieu baï koroma
varades pas de voeux pour les musulmans
quand on met de la religion partout y
compris dans les usages dans ce qu'on
appelle la courtoisie élémentaire c'est
qu'on mélange tout et qu'on ferait
parfois mieux de se taire on a envie de
dire à m gims au revoir et pas forcément
à bientôt mais restons comme une force
sur nos valeurs nos trucs m noël etc on
respecte
s'ils ne sont pas en fait
ce ne sont pas nos fêtes voilà venez on
se concentre sur nos convictions là j'ai
cherché et je n'ai pas trouvé pourquoi
les voeux de bonne année ne serait pas
conforme à l'islam j'ai posé la question
à tarik au bouquet l'imam de bordeaux et
qui a éclaté de rire en me disant on
dirait une mauvaise blague c'est un peu
comme si quelqu'un demandé aux musulmans
de ne plus dire bonjour très sincèrement
je m'en fiche un petit peu un de ce que
m higgins france de la bonne année ou de
souhaiter bon anniversaire je ne sais
pas il cessa jamais été la boussole
morale de qui que ce soit et
éventuellement ça peut décevoir certains
de ses fans qui se disent bas quand même
il rendait y vend des millions de
disques non mais on est d'accord on le
c'est un sujet c'est qu'il vend des
millions de disques et je parle à des
jeunes c'est un discours qui peut avoir
tendance à radicaliser sur des positions
assez difficilement compréhensible
souhaiter la bonne année c'est une
politesse c'est un code social qui n'a
rien de religieux conclusion que cet
imam il vaut mieux laisser la chanson au
chanteur et la théologie au théologie il
a sans doute raison quand même
globalement l'imam mais cela dit là il
dit sur les réseaux sociaux à des
millions de personnes en mode en fait on
a notre nos propres codes on ne respecte
plus qu'un dry ça nous permet de prendre
un peu davantage en considération le
fait que les propos tenus par les
artistes de variété les rappeurs et
cetera hors cadre musical généralement
sont pas toujours très intéressant
peut-être qu'on pourrait leur accorder
un petit peu moins d'importance si j'ai
envie de bien au maitre gims très bonne
année à vous et franchement profiter
c'est merveilleux d'être en france de
pouvoir se dire la bonne année de
pouvoir être bienveillant les uns avec
les autres et on vous souhaite que le
meilleur
[Musique]
ennemi à
2022 20 sa sono déjà mieux clé
[Musique]
c'est le s quand c'était assez de danser
en 2020 c'est à celle dans ces cétacés
dedans fm il resto bar on a fini ben
fini
et puis la bombe h en effet
françaises français mes chers
compatriotes
deux métropoles d'outre-mer et de
l'étranger 2021 se retire sur la pointe
des pieds je vous souhaite donc du fond
de mon coeur de français bonheur et joie
bonne année à la france de la république
et surtout vive la france pendant des
années elle pensait le lui du pied elle
pensait lui du pied elle découvre rien
dire
si l'on pouvait mettre correctement ce
qu'il est pendant des années elle
pensait lui faire du pied et il parle de
marine le pen elle découvre qu'en fait
c'était la courte échelle il y a une
règle en politique qu'en flirte avec
elle avec plus extrémistes avec plus
extrémistes qui gagne franchement c'est
n'importe quoi comme une image vaut
mille mots celle ci symbolise le nouveau
protocole sanitaire à l'école pour
lutter contre le coc vide ceux qui
jugent les mesures gouvernementales
insuffisante partage également cette
vidéo d'un stadier totalement inefficace
et puis il ya l'option détournement avec
le film mission impossible protocole
fantôme et jean michel blanquer en tête
d'affiche dans ce nouveau protocole si
les élèves sont positifs au co vide il
s'isole sept jours et peuvent retourner
en classe dès le 5e jour à condition de
n'avoir plus aucun symptôme et un test
antigénique négatif s'ils ont un cas
positif dans leur classe ils doivent
réaliser un test négatif pour revenir en
cour ils recevront ensuite deux auto
test à utiliser deux jours plus tard et
quatre jours plus tard on a appris en
fin d'après-midi et la disparition
d'igor bogdanoff à l'âge de 72 ans six
jours après le décès de son frère jumeau
grichka les deux frères devenu célèbre
dans les années 80 avec leurs émissions
temps x avait été hospitalisée le 15
décembre à paris après avoir contracté
le coville avait refusé de se faire
vacciner un jour l'un d'eux ou mourra
avant l'autre se scelle une perspective
ça s'est passé
non un soir de gala c'est jusqu'à je ne
suis plus qu'en parce que c'est au 29
janvier mais c'est complet donc on a
rajouté des dates aujourd'hui au théâtre
marigny ne faut pas out est marini oui
on pourra appeler le matin parce que ça
sonnait des places qui se libèrent pour
le soir mais un oui parce que par
exemple il ya des bogdanov qui qui dit
kim non pardon on a pas à dire ça non
mais plein de gens la même chose bonjour
quand je vais faire trois voeux ah ben
je préfère faire 3 3 doses si vous me
permettez mais bon que l'on parle un peu
moins de zemmour un peu plus d'amour que
l'on parle un peu moins du coc vide un
peu plus de la vie que l'on parle peu
moins des idées noires et un peu plus et
un peu plus de l'espoir l'espoir sinon
rien alors nous avons d'un côté sakura
qui habite à paris célibataire depuis
deux mois
de l'autre côté on a queen elle qui
habite à paris est célibataire depuis
vie moi je me reconnais dans deux
profils parce que ben on a je pense
qu'on a à peu près la même taille
d'implants mammaires
oui ça passe
c'était sur rick le soudeur de mike le
rejoint chez le ferrailleur mike est ce
que tu sens quelque chose ouais est-ce
que je vais répéter mon dieu on sort
d'ici
[Rires]